yeah hello and welcome to this video
about round eight of the CSTO tournament
let's get going again an interesting
round yeah some really exciting fighting
games first of all some words about the
games that I'm not going to cover we're
not going to cover the games kayaking
sole which was a very solid draw
hurry Krishna ye also pretty solid draw
when very near promenade she was a very
long fighting game which also ended in a
draw
um that could have been something that
he can could have shown but there's just
so much in the other games I don't want
to hit and I don't want the video to be
extremely long so let's get going with
the game alien off vojta check and again
he for battalion off he's really has
broadened his opening repertoire playing
or opening moves now color Sicilian
green light off as water Shack usually
plays and but should be to the classical
continuation played by Geller and Karpov
it should be called the Geller system
actually but it doesn't really have a
name it's one of those lines that
probably will never get completely out
of fashion and that's very logical and
solid white is going to Castle short
quite quickly play with f4 oftentimes d5
Knight b3 and we see this line this has
gotten into some fashion in in recent
years the idea in itself is of course
known since galas games back in the 60s
white puts knight on d5 and once at the
end to get this pawn structure the form
pawns here against the three pawns and
wants to advance those pawns trying to
yeah built at the end a pestle on the
queenside this is a very Ellis head
classical strategy that is still played
as we see to their day
it filled some very it feels slow
actually if you look at this white is
building up there yeah but it will lead
invariably to very sharp play because
white with this expansion threatens to
suffocate black and black has to find
counter play and we see with f5 the
counter play is coming so f3j trade it
f4 so black is really putting his hopes
on this g5 attack this has definite
resemblance to the King's Indian white
on the Queen side black on the King side
he moved the night here over to e form
here and those Knights got traded now we
see this in its purest form form begins
three and white very quickly here push
ahead yeah how to evaluate this position
it's very difficult to do actually even
though if you use a computer for help
it's really tough to save how this
should be evaluated because them black
attacking chances should never be
underestimated
I mean I have I've been shaking made it
so often in the white side over Kings
Indian I really know from experience
that I mean this the Queen coming and
Knight the airport and so on this is
dangerous on the other hand White's
attack here is fairly quick so we have
c5 Queen g5 and c6 yeah here if you give
the engine some time it will it wants to
play rook b8 and actually can evaluates
the position as roughly equal I don't
really know what to make of that
I'm very unsure I know the and the
engines are tremendously strong but it's
difficult to say does it really feel or
does it see the engine some kind of
Perpetual coming on the horizon
it only is clear that the computer does
not like this move Bishop takes a6 and
g3 this seems to be not enough and if we
I mean even with the human eye we can
see quite quickly if we go ahead a
couple of moves that probably blacks
attack is not quick enough
so here white has to capture oftentimes
you see white or anything and it doesn't
matter if it's white or black that some
the defender uses this pawn as a shield
rather than taking it it wants to yeah
you want to keep it on the board even
though here knight eh v g3 looks a bit
problematic so it does make sense to
just take it him and I mean if you look
at this it it feels like white should be
able to defend us if you ask me
the pawn structure situation on the
kingside is clarified so an attack would
probably be based on pieces and it
doesn't feel to me that there are enough
pieces for black even though there's the
rest of uncertainty uncertainty them
yeah d5 trying to make it as complicated
as possible like a second this pawn to
get the knight into the game to f5 yeah
here d6 was played by Ali enough
he wants to speed this up and irritate
the night I mean he wants to make this
piece take on his success what I'm
trying to say this was not played after
Queen d5 check Knight back this is just
to passively placed and I mean if white
is not getting checkmated he will win
with the Queen side yeah even if you
lose a piece and the process quite often
you will win because the pawns are so
far advanced yeah this is not a good
line for black after d6 he played the
check and now talked with the Queen and
I enough I did this on purpose he didn't
just blunder the porn
this is winning him some
to coordinate yeah he checked here on c4
King h8 and b5 this is I think a very
logical play the engine suggest some
improvements but this is I mean if you
just if you look at such a game with
both players having them at a time and
you look what an almost perfectly
playing computer is saying you can your
bit missing the point because we treat
humans nobody is going to play this
perfectly at just an extremely difficult
struggle where the better calculator
will probably win or the person with the
better nurse so I mean the computer will
find all kinds of improvements but it's
completely unrealistic to expect them
those moves to be played on the board
all the time
Ruby g7 was played that yeah that
certainly makes some sense and we see a
rook g3 there are ideas for counter play
quite clearly rook t1 was played in 94
looks completely normal
this move it seems that maybe Queen c5
was a little bit better but ok 94 yeah
and he in this position except that my
notes yeah sorry in this position for
example Here I am
the computer here wants to play the move
King edge 1 and says that this is quite
a good idea for wider no no human being
is going to play that move it just
doesn't happen it just doesn't happen
what what alien off did is perfectly
logical for a human player he identified
the knight as being dangerous and just
took it based on the fact that traits I
mean ok I know this is a rook and this
is a knight it's not an even trade
but the trades actually helped white to
avoid getting checkmated and the pawns
will win on their on their own accord if
you're not going to
be mated Queen d3 this is a perfectly
logical idea you want to trade queens
and of course black should not let
Quincy fire Queen B 2 is a little bit
clearer yeah you're going to threaten
made immediately and this is after
Bishop d5 every three leading to a draw
Bishop takes e4
I know it's pure it's pure computer but
this is something that a human player
can find because it's fairly logical to
drop those two pawns to activate
everything and now you've broken down
the pawn formation here and it's quite
it feels quite reasonable that this is a
draw he played queen c5 this still seems
to be okay just computer why it's okay
um but it's different it's far more
difficult rook f3 good defensive move
and now Queen to e7 was played yeah it
seems that rook f6 was better but you
know they are not computers check black
can go back 25 Queen d7 and this is
coming yeah so that was better
27 and Bishop d5 and make sensor
blocking in the pawns and preparing B
625 rook h3 yeah and here here black
probably should have played f3 similar
to what we've seen before white is
probably better but the result of the
game is it's hard to hard to predict
yeah it's such an extremely sharp
position he should probably drop this
and then oops not this one play look
rook d8 trying to activate this when he
played this he probably under as
summated I'm sorry Queen f3 was the move
Queen f3 was the move move 40 yeah and
with this
why does avoiding the tactic that
happened in the game
that was yeah very easy to overlook yeah
here white has consolidated he is
controlling it for now and the winning
idea well it's very obvious in the game
he played this immediately and now black
had a safe like just about a safe
efore hmm and at the same time
threatening mate that's quite important
yeah there is no c7 or something like
that yeah checkmate what has to take and
now f3 amazingly clearing this path with
a check there is a check White has to
take root cheeks and now c7 yeah Black
has one dispute c7 trying to promote
yeah and now we near five is just about
the draw yeah and it's a perpetual here
white can of course not avoid the 71
white gets shake made it yeah what a
dramatic position and white has those
pawns and black just about to manage the
draw I know I did not analyze this in
extreme detail because you know you
can't analyze since these positions and
crude all those computer lines but
nobody's nobody is going to play this
kind of thing perfectly and it just
would feel I think wrong to criticize
the players too much for what they did I
think it was a great fight and a draw is
not not an unknown not an unfair result
in any way I think it was just a great
great battle
in the next game I want to look at is a
game Audubon and Dracon yeah LaVon is
starting a winning streak
he was down like minus 2 at the bottom
of the table and anyone games against
kayaking and Android to Shaq and today
he had white against and reckon so
but do we have Kings gambit again no no
93 the Vienna game with g3 this is an
interesting opening by the way like this
or even I'm sorry Knight f6 g3 this is
an interesting opening line that I can
recommend to players who want a full
strategic better with white with very
little theory to learn so it's not bad
white is trying to build up slowly with
this and maybe later go for a 4
not bad at all I mean like an equalized
but it's something different and
absolutely absolutely a good surprise
weapon at least
yeah and drinking played knight c6
Knight f6 and again g3 they played a
symmetrical kind of set up until re-bond
went F for the white setup looks a
little bit like a closed Sicilian with
black okay as a pawn on e5 then I think
the first couple of moves felt very
logical and I should get my notes yeah
felt quite logical
however after Bishop e3 c5 22 now it
really looks like a Sicilian quite a lot
22 castles Knight f4 yeah now I'm I'm
drinking decided to take on f4 and
allowed this traitor of the bishops this
is um always going to be a little bit
dangerous for black without that dark
squared bishop however it shouldn't be a
fatal weakness
it still is something that I wouldn't
enjoy so much with black giving up this
bishop the King is a little bit insecure
and also you lose a little bit of grip
in the center like the knight on d4 so
he took it and invited the Queen over to
age six in a way so he has to be very
very cautious now that there is no
Knight coming to g5 for example at first
he handled this okay I think here would
be five typical move in this kind of
situation that got pushed back and now
look f1 yeah and the next couple of
moves I think somehow go totally wrong
for black I feel that this is already a
little bit uncomfortable if you ask me
White's position is a lot easier to play
and he has a straightforward way of
continuing he is got the knight on c3 is
not that great if you can move it for
example like this or in the game he went
Knight be one and so on if you can
improve this and get it towards the
Kings side then it definitely can become
dangerous for black also this piece
might be expelled to c3 it feels a bit
passive black situation you played Queen
d8 and this is probably already getting
him into some issues 91 now would have
been fairly strong going over to e3
potentially even having Knight f5 in
mind this is getting very dangerous for
black instead audubon when tonight b1
the idea is c3 and 90 to f3 oh that was
wrong error didn't want that maybe try
this route and the next move now is
definitely putting black into huge
issues maybe you should have played
something that King h8
some defensive move but he went d5 and
this move I just feels very illogical to
me in a way because after 92 White will
get the Knight to e4 either after taking
a black taking on e4 or white taking on
d5 so why why did he allow the Knights
to be activated like that I really not I
mean next position is is not nice but I
think this helped y tremendously yeah he
no too corny for even and 19 say and now
you see white threatens made and this
and bought at the same time that's not
going to work out
he tried 9f5 but here white has a simple
recipe just take it take it
yeah yeah okay we have to I was a bit
quick so take him so what what happens
after the other captures Bishop takes
yeah
just wins very easily or the politics
the media check things like that are
happening so this is the best try but
now you can do we can do a simple count
White has two nights
active nights for rook air-five and yeah
90s g6 was also possible but 95 is just
simple and good threatening the maid on
age 7 and this ending is just winning
for whites I you know he's got night and
Bishop and pawn
yeah and position where the pieces have
good yeah good positions good outpost
that say the bishop is very safe the a
pawn is strong yeah I did a good job
zone just going for the ending a porn
got rolling and you can even ignore this
as a2 is covered so here a 7 the pawn
promotes
look see 192 a 92 is a nice little trick
I mean it was necessary you can also win
just about pure technical play well this
is still nicer it covers this so so
threatening a 7 if black takes a 7 again
promotes pretty neat like played the
Czech King III takes but white is
quicker and now white checks first check
has to go to f6 to check again has to go
there Bishop f7 here White has a force
checkmate
like this yeah check and mate so we get
another win for re-bond he now has won
three games out of the last form and
with +1 this all of a sudden in the top
half of the tournament table great great
turnaround and a good fighting game a
little bit I mean I don't quite
understand what what what so tell what
went so terribly wrong here it still
felt fairly normal for black and I think
probably the combination of getting the
Queen into age 6 and then Queen d85
those moves that was was too much white
was just yeah activated too much by this
plane ok the next game I want to check
is the game why is it a Romney and Gary
remember here we had this marathon game
in the wrong before where he
miraculously escaped this checkmate by
the world champion somehow that cars
didn't play so what happened today
Aronian is white and we've got a Catalan
opening here he goes for the closed
defense with the Czech inserted in our
c6 so one point of blacks player is to
give this check on before - yeah get the
bishop to d2 it is usually argued that
the bishop is worse on d2 then on c1 as
white quite often wants to fear cairo it
aronia now
and plays a really uncommon set up or
let's say a new setup that at least I
have not yet seen in a game and it's a
it seems to be new
93 just put the light down
oftentimes white moves the bishop for
example to f4 to free the D 2 square he
just put the light down to develop with
a quick look see one that's interesting
what this does is that it asked black
about his plans for the c8 Bishop the
normal way for black to develop this
piece is to play with b6 if you do this
now white might take and now use the C
file quite favorably for example 9 p5 is
an immediate idea but after a six the
knight cannot jump into c7 all that
comfortably yeah so it's not that easy
but white can do this
trying to play vision before maybe
trading this piece and still having 95
as an option that's an interesting way
of developing the game you can also play
Bishop f4 c7 of course this idea so
against b6 it feels like white has
interesting plane gear we went 94 also
pretty commonplace in this position or
these position types and Bishop e3 now
by aronia yeah this is a an absolute key
point of the game the Giri now decides
to change the pawn structure in a
radical way he took the night and played
926 quite interesting with the double
pawn to c4 pawn now is without any
support and this provokes wide to play
c5 it turns out that after Knight c4
Aronian just took this and if you look
at his spend time it's clear that this
was part of the
preparation I mean he's certainly also a
kind of player who could sacrifice the
exchange here without having prepared
this at home
but judging from the time spent it was
clearly something that he had seen
before so Queen c2h6 covering against
95s quincy for White has a pawn for the
exchange
black couldn't really go b5 in the
situation after 95 you see that this is
immediately hanging so h6 Queen takes
default White has a pawn for the
exchange
he's got the bishop pair and this is the
main point blacks pieces extremely
passive the knight here is very passive
and especially in the bishop and white
now has a very easy game I think this is
already a very nice position for white
that also computers quite clearly under
or miss evaluated a little bit I think
white is better and it's especially
difficult to play with black so the
computer gives white a slight advantage
don't get me wrong but in a practical
situation this is terrible for black
yeah you're super passive and you have
no clear plan what to do
b6 tried beggary and now Aronian gets
the Bishop over to d6 very simple this
is very simple to play with white you
just play all the natural active moves
and expand in 95 and here
look how passive this is trade it good
idea usually I'm to trade making things
simpler to defend but the white position
is just too active yeah he look at those
it's a terrible position forgive me to
play and Aronian isn't playing quickly
it's it's very easy to to put pressure
on black here yeah now his shifting is
attention towards the King side
it's almost a full exchange you know
this is not really a bond but what are
the rooks doing
I mean bishops can be extremely strong
if they can use their long range
capabilities and here we see in a bishop
over sorry that was the wrong button the
bishops switching over here yeah being
aimed towards the Kings side on one of
those City on one of those positions and
the bishop on d6 I mean this is just
better than a rook rook b7 of course not
trading keeping the pressure on why does
not want to trade one of his pieces
that's absolutely not good in this
position I'm actually the Queen trade
was giving white a pretty big advantage
but it's not a good idea practically
because you see already that with this
bishop geared towards the king there
will be chances to attack the King and
if you can do that you should keep this
opportunity okay this is good though but
it's just better keep the Queen's on
keep the pressure on this is just more
annoying the bishop on the a8 will never
defend the black King this is important
to understand why does attacking here
with two bishops basically against the
rook as the 8th Bishop doesn't count so
he's just lining up everything yeah
black is doing this to prevent a 425 and
this is an absolutely terrible situation
he has given back the exchange but white
is just attacking here again this is a
bishop down and now the black rook
cannot move because of the checkmating
threat on g7 when did ya can give some
respite shakes but yeah here it's over
yeah so a very clean and very convincing
win in Verona
I think this is probably a combination
or this is this game resulted because of
or came up with because of two reasons
you is a very tiring game in the round
before 120 something moves and coming
back from the dead of course you can say
his yeah he escaped defeat and and so on
but it's still a pretty tough experience
sitting there in the loss position for
the whole time and the second thing is I
think it stepped onto a real yeah mine
of an opening preparation Aronian had a
fantastic position after the exchange
sec and it was extremely difficult to
defend and you probably maybe he can
defend us and when he's and his absolute
best but that just not likely to be the
case after the game from the day before
so final game to cover his report with
white against Magnus cars and what did
the were champion do report place then
is solid for his standard and not bad of
course yeah why should this be a bad
opening it's the Queen's Indian
something reversed and in fact we get
very quickly a position with g3 that is
usually coming up via a reti opening
move order its Knight f3 c4 g3 this is
actually a position that I've had on the
board myself quite a number of times
what white wants to do in the setup is
ideally he wants to expand on the
queenside with before maybe queen up
rook c1 he wants to build up and play on
the Queen side sometimes it's an issue
for black that the bishop on f5 isn't
doing all that much it looks at this
very protected pawn and has little has
little to attack this theme
this bishop will come up later in the
game as well okay first of all a five to
prevent before and queen bee one one of
the typical ways to set this up
I've often played with Quincy to Bishop
c3 queen bee to in these situations
queen bee one to Bishop age seven yeah
we treating this as a precaution against
a four or nine H form and yeah he report
immediately played the move before
that's not a very common motif but of
course it's it's absolutely playable
cars took it and now we have to check
what happens if black captures on before
if it takes on before of course Bishop
f6 is a tempo on the Queen
so I'm winning a piece here with white
black cannot take this and set that
Queen to b6 that's also perfectly okay
Bishop c3 covering this now and taking
on a1 yeah so what about this can black
take on before yeah this is what Carson
played you don't have to do this but if
you don't take on before you have to
reckon with white playing c5 and gaining
space so I understand why you took just
avoiding this long-term bind and the
move rupee one now can be answered with
Bishop takes so that does not work but
white with this sequence can regain the
b7 pawn so what did happen yeah we have
some trades we had some trades there on
the Queen side and other than that it's
hard to believe that society could be
better
the black bishop is not doing much am
looking at a protected pawn but the
white bishop certainly isn't doing that
much either
yeah it's looking at a roll of pawns
there should be somewhat equal cards are
played a5 playing actively I mean he
definitely wants to try to do something
in this game so e5 is certainly an
interesting
however it gives a wide a little bit
more with this Bishop as now the pawn on
d5 is not that securely defended yeah
reporters playing this interesting me
now not staying passive or waiting
he played D for initiating a crisis in
the center so what should black do you
can of course look at Evo and gaming
space but after 95 this looks quite nice
for white the bishop now is looking at
its own pawn so that's not great and
white is also intending to play c5 look
at c6 this is a pretty weak --is-- pawn
so e4 is probably not a good idea what
Carlton plain is fine he took this pawn
Knight takes and played c5 this is a
good way of doing this the knight is
attacked and now went back to b3
Knight b5 and doesn't really do all that
much
it looks more active but after Queen e6
this is also hanging so this is a good
move and cards play d4 gaining a bit of
space yeah so what did report to Bishop
83 mm looking at the d7 Knight we have
to check this position because it is an
absolutely critical moment of the game
note that Carlton has played quite
quickly up to this point and now went on
with the move d3 he played this after a
very long thought and this makes it all
the more mysterious mysterious is strong
word but I mean first of all if he plays
something simple like this he is just
okay yeah white can take this black
captures there is no reason why this
position shouldn't be equal you know
pieces are somewhat equally active and
there are no particular weaknesses
on either side so we decided to avoid a
solid continuation and played the move
t3 okay
what does report do we just place a
three simple simple reply and it's a bit
difficult here to see the upside of
blacks play because the pawn on d3 okay
it's a passer but it's very very
securely defended by the knight on D
tomb
and it's not clear what blacks big
achievement is however the real issue a
thing starts with the next move I mean I
think white is a bit better now but
after 95 I think Carlton gets into
trouble very quickly and Bishop g2 is a
good move by report that Bishop did not
do anything anymore on a3 with the
bishop coming back he's looking at the
critical long diagonal covering they're
three square and white has a clear idea
now forward to push eform
and f4 note that with playing the pawn
to d3 that bishop now looks like a real
dummy that doesn't look good from lucky
the awkward thing is if you if you asked
the computer it wants to play now the
only move that black can play without
getting into immediate disaster
basically is to play the knight back to
the 7 where it came from and this is not
a move you want to play and a very human
player I mean it's very reluctant to do
it this is not a matter of pride it's
just it feels like ok then that makes it
like a total failure can we do something
else and Kazon tried to play rook c8 but
after f4 and E 4 we see how awkward this
is ie 5 is a big threat and what is
exactly is black doing here yeah he has
absolutely no active play those pieces
just look actor
they don't do that all that much now the
night here also has very little squares
to go to 23 is rare a possibility but if
white covers this where's the night
going
this position is already winning for
white if you ask the computer and it
looks terrible v5 is coming cards and
try droopy 8 and then if I've played a
report yeah why not
Cakes takes takes and white is a piece
up however it takes some precision to
make a full point out of it and report
is up to the task is a very good
calculator root b6 now it's a very nice
move looking at the Queen and yeah I
mean black what counsel no does does not
work but there is nothing that actually
does so he played this yeah jack yeah
and now report has seen that would be
six now the winning combination or the
winning sequence Bishop c6 is very
strong looking at this and we know the
King cannot escape the bishop on h7 is a
really unlucky piece and rook takes the
eight is almost mate yeah and winning
the Queen after Luke f1 rook e1 check
white could sacrifice the screen and now
play Knight f1 and it's a really unlucky
spot Roop takes the eight again it's
almost checkmate so the Queen has to he
has to give up itself and there's no way
out d2 but just takes it and there are
no checks the knight is the King's best
friend is a famous saying and is really
often is the case yeah King f8 who p8j
and yeah white is just a piece of and
will win easily
so report beating Carlton yeah with an
interesting game and I think also a game
there
we see similar to give his game this has
a clear connection to the game in the
round before but he missed a median 3
and it really feels like here he didn't
want to play something yeah
something normal in a way something that
is likely to be a draw wanted to
continue and fight with d3 but that just
seems to be a strategic mistake as it
turned out in the game yeah this is
something that happens to cars and once
in a while he sometimes just once too
much yeah if you look at Jonathan rouses
a famous book the 7 deadly chest sense
Colin sometimes has this wanting wanting
to win wanting to do more than the
position warrants sometimes he has that
not like all the time is of course a
brilliant player usually but sometimes
he loses this sometimes sense of
objectivity what you can try to try to
do and whatnot and here d3 just didn't
work I mean report played it played it
nicely and with this should be 2 and F 4
and so on but it wasn't exactly rocket
science him that it really wasn't so I
think this game has to be seen in clear
context with them the round before what
does that mean Townsend is down to just
a +1 score and will be difficult for him
to to do something in the tournament
yeah is one point now behind Wesley so
and I mean he's the kind of person who
can come back from such a rotten game
but doesn't look all that all that great
yeah I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
round eight on Monday there will be a
rest day so players will be back on
Tuesday when I will also do the video
for round 9 thanks for watching bye bye